Hello Freak bitches.
You know when I think it's one of the
things that I've been guilty of and I know
a lot of other people have been guilty
of it too just to totally come clean.
I defend pot so much that I never look
at the potential negative consequences of
people doing pot if they're too young
because I didn't do it when I was down.
Army did a few times,
maybe like a handful of times before I
was 30 and then when I was 30 I met Eddie
Bravo. We started getting blazed all the
time and it changed the entire world.
Pot I smoked pot was 14 I'd, well I
definitely smoked it younger than that.
I smoked when I was eight
my Stepdad gave me someone.
I was eight just to a puff cause I
was curious. I was like, what? What?
What happens when you do it? He
goes, do you want to try it? I said,
how much should I breathe? And he
goes, don't breeding in it a lot.
Just breathing a little bit.
This is obviously like sketchy memory.
I did it once when I was eight and then
the next time I did I was probably like
14 and then I did it probably maybe again
when I was 14 when we cut school and
some of the kids,
a couple of kids that were the cool guys
that I kind of took a liking to me and
I was like, cool, the cool kids like me,
I'm going to go hang out with these dudes.
They smoked weed and I remember I hit it
and very, and they were telling me like,
have you ever smoked weed or
no, I never spoke with her. I'm,
nothing might happen
to you the first time.
But I remember vividly hitting this
joint with these dudes and literally
spending probably an hour and 30 minutes
laughing my balls off that. Nothing.
And I thought it was the greatest
thing ever and from then on I was like,
I quit baseball.
No it pop Warner became an artist.
I started drawing and painting on walls.
I was like, I was a different person.
That changed my life.
We eat is another thing that's
probably semi responsible for my path.
I had a very important moment when I was
16 I got only smoked weed a handful of
times before I was 30 years old,
like less than 12 like legitimately and
a one time when I was 16 it was me and
my girlfriend and my best friend
who went over her house and uh,
I had stole some weed for my Stepdad and
we had rolled up a joint and we got so
high we were teleporting. We would
like find ourselves in the kitchen,
astral cleaning type shall be staring at
each other on the couch and then all of
a sudden we'd be in the backyard.
We were barbecued.
We were were fucking 16 I
think my girlfriend at the
time was 15 had Josh was my
age,
he was,
he was 16 and we were just time traveling
all over the fucking building. It was,
we were way too high. That's
how I described the, for the,
the first and only time I ever smoked
dust. Oh Jesus. He did that. Well,
I hung out with like when I was one
of the neighbors as I moved into this.
Is there a fucky gateway drug
to dust as it's called Solos,
like Lowe's? Did they go right from
Diet Pepsi to dust? I don't know.
Here's my story is I moved onto this
street called Independence Avenue in,
in the valley. It's like West valley
kind of Desoto Sherman Way Ish.
And it was heavily Latino neighborhood
and like we moved in and it was cool.
I mean like I lived here, I came friends
with a lot of people, but like, um,
I went from like the end of elementary
school into junior high right in that era.
So like once we hit the junior high,
it's like a lot of the domestic
in kids I was hanging around with,
started hanging out with you a little
bit older Mexican kids and a lot of them
were dealing in like kind of
gang life over there. Um, uh,
it's just part of the way they get down.
And then so,
and a lot of them like to fucking do dips,
which is like a fucking sherm cigarette
dipped into my fucking angel dust angel
dust. Sounds like healthy choice dude's
out. It's how I wound up with this,
this little tattoo right here.
First Tattoo I ever had in my life.
This little three dots.
Normally it's supposed to be up here,
but I wasn't in a gang. Oh. And
so it's like for some reason they,
I was so fucked up. This is
what wound up, I mean this,
this represents what they
call them a Mi Vida loca.
It's like little three dots here,
but it's like that happened because I
smoke dust because these dudes pass me the
sherm.
I didn't really know what I was looking.
I was like this bang and the literally
the way you just described that time
travel and it was like, I felt like
if I thought of something to do,
by the time I was finished with
the thought of thinking to do it,
I had already done it.
I'm going to call my mom goodbye mom.
That kind of thing.
It was like fucking nuts.
I fucking never experienced anything like
that. I was terrified. I was terrified,
terrified. I didn't know what the fuck is
going on. It was almost like, you know,
it gave me a lot of feelings is if you
remember the first Friday movie when
Chris Tucker reflects on like somebody
snuck in a little piece of dust,
any fucking la. It's, I didn't
lose my mind naked, all that shit.
But I feel like I was the butt
of a joke that night. Like,
like somebody gave me some dust.
It was like,
let's watch fucking the white
boy fucking trip on dust on it.
But it made for a good story on Joe Rogan.
So, no, I'm, you know, we're either,
okay.